and more than a month has passed since
the
beginning of the invasion of ukraine since the beginning of this cruel and senseless war
that like any war represents a
defeat for all for all of us
there is a need to repudiate the war place
of death where the fathers  and mothers
bury their children where men
kill their brothers without
even having seen them where the powerful decide the
poor die
the war not only devastates the present
but also the coming of a society
with a bed that from the beginning
from aggression to Ukraine  one
in two children has been displaced from the country
this means destroying the future
causing dramatic trauma in the
smallest and most innocent among us
here is the bestiality of war
barbaric act that
sacrilege war cannot be something
inevitable
we must not get used to war
we must instead  convert the indignation of
everyone of today into the commitment of tomorrow
because if we come out of this story
as before we will all be affected in some way
face the danger
of self-
destructing humanity understand that the
time has come to abolish war to
erase it from man's history
before you erase man from
history
I pray for every political leader to
reflect on this to commit to
this  that looking at the battered
Ukrainian to understand how every day of
war the situation worsens for everyone
so I renew my appeal
enough to stop and
shut up arms it is serious
for peace